くさぁぁ
こんにちは、はじめしゃちーです
これ本当くせえーな
ううううううう
ゔええ
はい、これ何かと言いますと
気持ち悪い赤ちゃんのお面です
怖いですねー
もう赤ちゃんなのかなこれ
青い筋がほんと怖いですね
本当これ臭そう臭そう
はい、というわけで..で..
この程のマスクを沢山買いました
待ってこれ何個あるんだろう
ちょっと数えてみます
えと全部でここに６０個のマスクがあります
くせえ
なんでこんな臭いの
リアルベイビーフェイスが
６０個あるんですけども
常識的に見てこんなのが家にあったら
すごい怖いと思うんです
てか普通に１個あれば怖いんですけど
この量、これだけ家にあると
めちゃくちゃ怖いと思うんですけども
今お家にですね
河童男が暫く遊びに来ております
で、後輩の河童男をちょっと
パッと脅かしたいと思いまして
何かいい作戦はないかなと思ったんですけど
河童男がもうすぐ家に帰ってくるんですけども
帰ってきて他の部屋にいる時に
家のブレーカーを落とします
家のブレーカーを全部落として
真っ暗になった時に
河童男にブレーカーを直しに行かせると
で、ブレーカーを直しに行って
電気をパッと戻して
光が明るくなった瞬かぁ↑あ↑ん！
周りが赤ちゃんの顔だらけ
はい、というわけで
えっと、電気つけた瞬間
自分の周り一面が
赤ちゃんの顔だらけドッキリを
やってみようと思います
では行こう
ブレーカー直してね
気持ちわる
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　も↑や↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓も↓やぁ↑　も↑や↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓も↓やぁ↑　もぉ↓や↓し↓　も↓や↑も↓やぁ↑しぃ↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！もっ！やっ！しっ！♬
気持ちわる